[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un journaliste l'interpellent et lui
demande regardez ce que poutine a fait à
ces gens que pensez vous de lui
notre grand pays est fier de chacun
d'entre vous comme zaz je tiens à vous
remercier pour votre fermeté bassim
ainsi que pour le service impeccable à
votre patrie pour l'amour de dieu cet
homme ne peut pas rester au pouvoir
que dieu vous bénisse que dieu bénisse
la liberté je pense qu'il faut d'abord
être factuel et ensuite en effet tout
faire pour ne pas que la situation
dérape je n'utilisais pas ce genre de
propos parce que je continue de discuter
avec le président poutine en grand
rendez vous ce matin jean-pierre
chevenet a déclaré avant de se livrer à
l'exercice traditionnel des injures
homérique vous devrez essayer de
réfléchir aux conditions qui permettent
de rétablir la paix phil est temps que
les française les français fassent un
choix de société le 10 avril qui va être
un choix de civilisation ne sommes plus
en guerre froide donc ensemble non parce
que ce qu'il faut voir ce qui se passe
depuis le 24 février ces deux visions de
l'europe opposé cette nouvelle guerre
froide elle est probablement inévitable
par les mentalités ont été bousculés
secoué par l'agression russe alors il ne
tient qu'à vous de choisir un autre
destin certains diront que j'exagère
mais regardez au cours dé vous regardez
vos villes regardez vos quartiers
regardez vos campagnes donc les états
unis profitent du conflit
incontestablement ils ont profité les
européens se jette dans leurs bras vous
les mécanos et les ingénieurs d'airbus
vous les chercheurs du spatial vous les
scientifiques vous aussi vous êtes le
meilleur de la france je suis venu vous
livrer un secret nous sommes les seuls à
être de droite dans cette campagne c'est
duplex dit perturbé par une
manifestation
nous allons voilà nous allons rompre
marine le pen est une socialiste en
économie qui ne veut plus prendre aucun
risque de déplaire aux médias sur les
sujets régaliens temps plein
enregistrement d'une interview pour
notre antenne marine le pen est molesté
son micro arraché il ya donc des gens
d'extrême gauche en france qui cherche à
faire taire la candidate qui est donné
possiblement au second tour cette
élection présidentielle ça ne convient
de voir est absolument inacceptable et
donc évidemment il faudra tout faire
pour que les clarifications soient
apportés et que la justice passe vous
êtes en permanence en train de tapoter
sur votre téléphone et peut-être que
vous n'écoutez pas mais répond pas du
tout je suis un homme et je les moyens
je vous écouterai grand témoignage non
mais je vous avoue que je peux
comprendre qu'au bout d'un moment mes
réponses ne vous conviennent pas mais je
vous les ai faites de façon très claire
et où d'une heure madame indiqué que la
personne la santé nous a dit maja la
plus forte pour l'instant c'est pas moi
qui voulais indiqué c'était les règles
de l'art comme suit d'isoler certains me
voyant et en lisant les sondages
disent qu'ils sont glacé d'effroi
c'est qu'il faut des cauchemars
à chacun son tour résistant à quoi
résistant système qui s'est emparée de
vous madame et qui a fait une personne
totalement enchaîné mouvement qui vous
ai connu six libre
de faire je vais vous faire les poches
résistons cenon parti à quoi correspond
il si vous ne vouliez pas ce qui ne vous
regarde pas et si vous me laissiez
répondre à mme à saint cricq vous le
sauriez alors allez-y bon si je vous
remercie beaucoup
à
merci beaucoup moi j'ai nous vous
remercier et bonne fin de campagne